hello and welcome to video playing our
for rock with blick all right Knight f3
[Music]
yeah let's play classical chess he is
not playing classical chess
okay what is he up to him
reversed Kings onion okay
hooray I'm better by mu4 that's not bad
I can probably just go deform but it's
not bad
okay so there are many ways now for
black to play one very direct one is the
H pawn push and I'm going to go for it
now why it has to be extremely careful
not to land in a really bad position so
[Music]
you know this is this is probably
probably the best the best choice yeah
I'm stopping 95 and g5 can be an option
for like for white I'm sorry F or black
Hispanic I'm black I'm playing the white
side of the Kings Indian of course this
is why I'm a little bit confused the lc3
tries to get some counter play them but
you never know that the CFR might be
useful for me I've got more space on
that side of the board
oh okay
it doesn't like his bishop it seems
okay yeah now if I go Queen before I'm
basically trading Queens and the Queen
trade is more or less winning here
I mean strategically White is basically
busted got more space two bishops g2 is
terrible
damn it adds up and now there's an issue
for white how did how do you play if you
move the Queen I'm just taking a two and
if you trade Queens d3 and yeah okay
he's so his giving is his in desperation
my what giving me this pawn the question
is if I take it I just wonder if I take
it there is Bishop age three
my latest air is not very desirable
Bishop age three but if he does that I
play Bishop b3 he has to go to be one
that says utterly ridiculous so I can
take let's do it it doesn't
what does what did he do we sure did
wrong okay so yeah just go back so now
most most principled movie is g5 let's
do it it's it's a bit that's very
ambitious but it is some ultra
principled okay that is threatening
nothing yeah so I can continue to win on
that side of the board
I'm threatening h3 here basically
putting the bishop out of business
totally so h3 Bishop back it's this is
one good line you can also think about
taking the issue is I mean I'm attacking
on the Kings side but my queen is
somewhere on before the Queen should
somehow join that it's not not so easy
to do let's take it and then see how to
continue if I move this Bishop and Queen
e7 yeah maybe he can play Knight f5 but
after taking its I don't see much and
maybe Knight a5 take and then he's got
90 to reform its maybe maybe possible
I need I need I need the other look here
in the game you know okay Jade coming
it's got too many bad pieces Bishop on
g2 and so on in particular the bishop is
bad
I didn't see why I cannot take this
it's not from me not the most principled
choice I had blunder this friggin power
down how unnecessary
run Forrest run and it will run all the
way all the way
everything under control now
hmm you know and this is the kind of
game that I enjoy your your better like
you have to move ten or so it's nice and
you have perfect control I'm absolutely
certain by the way that if you play like
this with white like just play the Kings
Indian reversed with d3 and allow this
that this is just better for black this
is not even equal because the closed
nature of the position the tempo is just
not relevant at all
in fact sometimes it is quite beneficial
for black even to be a tempo down one
one point is for example if you look at
this position let's say he played 93 but
in other cases also this quick h5 is
something that actually works better
with the night on G 8 so that this is
supported so if we look at how the game
went this like if I would have the extra
tempo the night here then H 5 makes no
sense because H 4 is not a threat this
is a different story here here each
tribe is good I have to say that if the
night would be here I would play in 97
also be in good shape it so this is
something that only works basically with
the tempo down and he decided now to
stop this it's a very difficult Collier
to make the problem is that whenever you
do would had some drawbacks the worst of
all is H 3 which after G 5 is clearly
better for black or you can also do this
and get the Petrosian clamp this is a
strategically almost winning position
for black the engines available six
second now it gets higher this is
strategically terrible we get many dead
pieces and black has just a huge space
advantage so I think relatively best is
probably H for it is given s
questionable here by the engine
I think you should stop this okay I went
they have six keeping g5 on the cards c3
Knight aged six and he decided to take
this okay and now rook c1 yeah probably
it's hard to give white advice early
maybe it's better to try to move the
knight and play a form the issue with
the night movements whenever you do that
let's say here I go g5 let's say he goes
f4 and now I have an interesting choice
I can take which is favored by the comp
just for an attack but a move that is
also quite playable is this this is also
just better for black that the engine is
giving white an advantage is totally
ridiculous really this is just showing
that the engine has no understanding of
this position because that that these
are all dead pieces and I mean black is
just better that's what it is you have
you you don't quite know where you put
the King but black is better however I
understand that the engine favours
something like this and trying to do
something here okay rook c1 was played
Queen b6 Queen a form and here something
like Queen f7 or aq King f7 or a5 s even
better maybe this is a good move I mean
he has to give up that pawn or trade
Queens and the Queen trade is terrible
however Wow
the engine is giving a cool move here it
wants to sacrifice interesting and this
is indeed interesting because I have
once this is opened my coordination is
not fantastic this is a bit odd I had
still 0.4 at 1.5 for me but from a
practical point of view they make some
sense if you play something slowish
you're just toast
this is hanging at this
hanging some okay he played Quincy - and
I grabbed the pawn if he now would have
played Bishop h3
this is sending the Queen back to b1 and
I cannot believe that that black is in
danger here with the Queen him
you played 92 it was kind of normal
okay so the engine did not like the
capture on g3 I mean I saw this but I
wasn't sure how to continue thanks yeah
sorry I try to prevent that but I think
it was on the sound my ah okay
yeah h2 I mean it must be better but I
wanted to open the position so yeah that
was not the best it's still pretty huge
advantage but yeah it seems that I
didn't screw it up at least yeah was
some big mistake in the term trouble but
it's important to note I really think
white should not allow this kind of
thing I mean if he played d3 very early
but if you for example play like this
with white I have played this quite
frequently with white I think you
absolutely should play D form before
reviewer screen for this is a lot better
then a reversed Kings Indian classical
variation okay guys thanks for watching